date are we writing saying that donnie
street hasn't yet received the sugree
report that's correct and of course it's
an independent report it's uh a matter
for sue gray
when she sends that report when she's
when she's completed her work okay when
she does we will see all of it
we have been absolutely clear that we
will publish the findings of the report
we do we don't know the content of the
report so there could be
for example security issues that mean uh
parts of it are problematic to publish
but we will absolutely publish the
findings of the report and we'll be able
to say more when we see the report sure
i mean previously last week i think
downing street said that they would repo
publish the report in full
that's basically the same it's what
you're saying exactly it's a national
security issue
well unless there is some specific issue
but we want to make the findings of the
report public
we want to be open and transparent
that's why sue gray has been asked to do
that report okay um
if he has broken the law or misled
parliament should he resign
the prime minister has appeared before
parliament
he has apologized
uh for what has happened he's admitted
that mistakes were made and i 100
support him
and want him to continue as prime
minister this is what he actually said
on the 8th of december if you'll just
indulge us we'll share this with our
viewers here we go
i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i was also furious to
see that clip
i have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged
that there was no party
and that
and that no
kovid rules were broken
if it's proven that he was at a party
should he resign i'm not going to
prejudice the findings
of the su grey report
or indeed
or indeed the police investigation that
is now taking place about what happened
what i'm saying kay
is the prime minister has apologized for
what has happened he said mistakes were
made
i believe that he's done a fantastic job
as prime minister
whether it's delivering brexit
uh delivering the covered vaccines the
booster programmes we've now got a much
faster growing economy than many of our
competitors thanks to his work and i
believe that's what we should focus on
uh well um you can't prejudice the
report of course because she's already
done it um the question is
when i suppose let me ask you this then
when were you aware of the police
investigation
i was aware yesterday when it would be a
before investigation before or after um
cabinet
well personally i was aware after
cabinet yeah apparently all your
colleagues in cabinet were aware after
cabinet but the prime minister knew
before do you think he should have told
you before
well i
i found out after capitalism same time
as the rest of us
well i'm you know i think it was made
public and it's a matter the police are
not
their operation the independent from the
government so i think it's right that
the
government finds out after the police
have made have made that decision and
after the public as well this is uh this
is what crested dick uh said yesterday
just in case you missed it
there was evidence that those involved
knew
or ought to have known
that what they were doing was an offence
do you think she needs the prime
minister
well
we have to wait to see what is the
outcome of the police investigation in
the same way as we need to see uh what
the outcome is of the sue grey report
you'll appreciate kay
that i am spending the majority of my
time working on the very serious
situation uh with russia and ukraine
i'll come on to that where we have and
we'll come on actively we will come on
the point the point i'm making is i'm
not following every single in and out of
definition if your prime minister is
about to be questioned under caution the
first time ever i'm guessing that's way
up on your in your inbox no it's a
matter for the police okay but as
foreign secretary you must be concerned
if the prime minister is the first prime
minister ever to be questioned under
caution
well as i've said the prime minister has
apologized in parliament uh for what has
happened he said that mistakes were made
he commissioned the sugray report
he he commissioned we're talking about
hypotheticals here okay we're not are we
because we see we are absolutely well
there's a police investigation now and
that's been triggered by the fact that
photographs of the prime minister
where wine was near him um have been
given to the police we also know that he
was in the cabinet room um and there was
cake there as well i'm saying what you
were saying is speculation
what we need to do is wait for the
results of the suga gray report and the
police investigation tony blair said
that if he was questioned under caution
he would resign do you think that your
uh prime minister has the moral backbone
to do the same
well you know tony blair's got his own
opinions what i'm doing is waiting for
the outcome of both the secret report
and the police investigation
where we will get the full analysis
of exactly what happened uh yeah but
if i mean you're asking me to speculate
about i'm absolutely not absolutely not
mistrust i'm absolutely not all i'm
saying to you as foreign secretary if
your prime minister the first lord of
the treasury is uh likely to be
questioned under caution tony blair and
he was in that position said i will
resign rather than that happen i'm just
asking whether your prime minister has
the moral backbone to do the same
what i'm saying to you is that until we
see
the results of the investigation both
the sue gray report and indeed the
police investigation it would be foolish
to speculate okay little known defense
that the rules didn't apply apparently
to crime property
although it applied to the rest of us
didn't apply to crime property is that
something that the prime minister should
consider as a defense
as i've said you know we are waiting for
the outcome
which will give us well
i don't think it is a reasonable
question because
it is hypothetical speculation about the
future
rather than i'm just saying waiting for
the results of this there is there is a
loophole that says that you could have
events like this on crime property
number 10 i'm guessing is crime property
in fact i'm pretty sure it is uh should
that be something the prime minister
considers and then he isn't bringing the
whole party and government into district
i can assure you this is something in my
role as foreign secretary i'm not
looking at okay yesterday he certainly
didn't seem to have any ringing support
from the deputy prime minister this is
what dominic rabb said yesterday
the government will continue in all
eventualities
continuously in a stable way but i think
you're getting ahead of yourself uh
we'll wait for the outcome of the
inquiries that sue grey is conducting
hardly ringing endorsement does the
prime minister have your support he has
my 100
full support no unwavering
absolutely doesn't matter total support
he has my complete support very good uh
let's move on to rishi soon after uh
should we um he we know that the
chancellor i'm sure you saw uh the
allegations at this stage that um rishi
sunak was he was at this downing street
event that was actually uh paying
respects to the nhs workers that had
sadly lost their lives and then just a
couple of weeks later there was the
event in that room which is
several people including
the interior designer have told us that
she was at that event which she soon act
was also there uh does he have questions
to answer
as i said we are waiting for the results
of this investigation it sounds like
well the
sue gray report okay it sounds like it
so after sue grey sounds like it sounds
like it will come out very soon so i
suggest we wait
for the facts rather than discuss
various pieces of speculation
about what might or might have a
statement yesterday mistrust to say that
she was there because she'd been asked
uh to have a meeting with the prime
minister as i said yesterday i can't
believe that in the middle of a pandemic
an interior designer came down three
flights of stairs went into another
building and then into the incredibly
secure cabinet room without being
invited what we need kate is the full
facts and that means that sue gray who
has spoken to all of the people
involved in the situation putting those
facts together and giving us a full
picture okay i'm not going to comment on
this speculation or this claim by a
given individual so we're waiting for
sue gray's report but not for the police
investigation to conclude you'll be able
to talk to us more about what what went
on i'm very happy to come on your show
and say nothing grey reports has been
published and talk about what's in it
okay great i'm very happy to come on
your show yeah once the police have
completed their investigations and so
that's twice you've promised i'll make
sure that
i'm extremely keen to come on your show
i'm always delighted to have you as you
can imagine miss trust did you go to any
parties that's not speculation i didn't
any
no were you ever invited
no
are you hesitated
oh no i wasn't okay okay about it okay
some mps have said that we need a sense
of uh proportion over the prime minister
being given a bit of cake do you agree
look as i've said we need to wait to see
the outcome of the report and we need to
see exactly what happened and i don't
think it's helpful
to speculate on specific claims or
specific
accusations about what may or may not
have happened okay what about the full
facts okay we do uh what about this we
won't have to wait long apparently
scaring mps by suggesting the pm will be
able to uh scrutinize any letters of no
confidence that have been sent to the
1922 committee chairman that's not right
that can't happen well i have complete
trust in segrega and brady
to run the process properly it is a
confidential process he's always done
that in the past and i'm sure he'll
continue to do that completely
confidential or any scam and he does
have
you know he does have the complete
confidence of the parliamentary party
and the role he does okay this picture
of kiyostama um
given the police investigation into the
prime minister should the police also be
looking at what happened in durham in
april of last year when kiyostama was
having a beer and a body
indoors when it was not allowed this is
a matter for the police and one of the
great things about the united kingdom is
we have a police force that is
operationally independent
politicians don't go around deciding who
should be investigated and who should
not be investigated would it be because
i think it would be very dangerous
for to live in a country where
politicians get their opponents
investigated so it's a matter for the
police would it be further if the prime
minister of the land was investigated
and the leader of the opposition was not
it depends on the evidence and that's a
matter for the police there
picture there of him there you go there
he is in durham with a beer and a body
hey neither you or i
are police officers that's right we
don't we don't have the
uh ability to or we don't have the train
to look at the evidence to decide
whether or not uh that that should be
taken forward it's a matter for the
police should the police you can ask me
about matters for me
to do with foreign policy they don't
know if he broke the law unless he
invest they investigate so should they
at least investigate well i'm sure the
police are looking at all of these
circumstances okay and looking at
whether they should investigate which is
their job which they do very well here
we go safer ground ukraine what should
we do
well we are already supplying support to
ukraine we're supplying defensive
weapons uh we're providing economic
support
and we are urging russia to desist from
an incursion and we're making it very
clear
that if they were to do that there would
be severe economic cost to russia severe
sanctions we're working with our friends
and allies sanctions they would they
would target individuals uh they would
target financial institutions and they
would be coordinated with all of our
allies across
europe uh the united states and others
and what if russia decides to invade
economic sanctions would we be looking
at anything other than that
what we are doing is we are providing
defensive support to ukraine
we're bolstering nato so we've already
got enhanced forward presence we've
already got troops in estonia nato is
looking at what more it can do i was in
brussels on monday talking to the
secretary general about the uk
contribution to that
and we will also make sure
that there are severe consequences in
terms of sanctions
on russia yeah if they were to stage an
incursion i wonder if i could just ask
you about in individuals are being
sanctioned because we've heard obviously
what um joe biden has said and he's
suggesting that it should actually be
pres at the president president putin
also have individual sanctions to is
that something that we would support
we're not ruling anything out and we
will be bringing forward new legislation
to make our sanctions regime tougher so
we were able to target
more companies and individuals in russia
would be including president we'll be
bringing that forward in the next few
days i'm not ruling that out okay um i
wonder if i could just bring you back to
um almost out of time but i just wanted
to bring you back to a situation that
will concern lots of my viewers this
morning and that's a national insurance
increase i believe the cabinet is split
over that which side are you on cabinet
has made the decision to proceed with
the national insurance increase and
we're all behind that and there are no
you're not allowed to change that there
you are you want to we have a we have a
process we've made collective decisions
and we are moving forward so it's not
something that will be reconsidered no
to save the prime minister's skin
no okay um
final thought before i let you go and
normally i i've got maybe seven or eight
questions and i don't get through them
all i've done 16 17 that's because
you're not really giving me very much
this morning well you're asking me
questions about a report that hasn't
been published in an investigation that
hasn't been completed yeah but we do
have some facts to the extent um that
people that were actually at these
events have said that they were there
and we've also seen photographs of the
prime minister relaxing in the garden
and we've also seen evidence of the
prime minister saying that he wasn't at
events that he quite clearly was at
because other photographs have been take
being given to sue grey
well we've had
weeks and weeks of questions
about these events you've had
you've had lots of you've had lots of my
colleagues on your show
uh asking questions about these events
and
there are very serious
issues happening across the world i mean
this threat that russia is making to
ukraine
uh could have severe consequences not
just for europe but for global security
which is why
we are doing so much to
stop uh to
to get russia to desist maybe we need um
a third female prime minister to
navigate us through that
i've got absolute confidence in our
prime minister he's doing a great job
including on russia ukraine where the uk
is leading the effort to support
defensive weapons into ukraine to lead
the international sanctions effort he's
doing a lot of work to persuade our
allies to do more particularly to reduce
european dependence on russian gas